hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor and I have
personally been involved in over 300
property deals over the last 10 years
and in this video I want to talk about
property deal sourcing what does it mean
to be a deal sorcerer and you may hear a
lot of people talking about deals
sourcing or property flipping packaging
deals like what does it mean exactly
what are the different expressions mean
and should you be a deal sorcerer so
first let me say this if you hear people
talking about flipping properties on a
property flipper that is very different
from a property sorcerer a property
sorcerer a property packager or deal
packager it doesn't deal seller that all
means the same things a property flipper
is someone who finds a property deal
they buy it they do it up and then they
pass it on to someone else so they flip
it on to someone else that's a property
flipper a property sorcerer and you may
also have heard people call them
describe themselves as a trader by trade
deals I'm a deal trader I'm a deal
package a deal saw sodor seller that all
means the same thing I don't know why
there's so many different expressions
for it but what that is is that is when
you find a deal you don't buy it you
don't own it
you just find it you negotiate it at a
set price and then you pass it on to an
investor for a fee effectively you're
like a broker in the middle now the
great thing about being a deal saw so
I'm gonna talk about what the good
things the bad things hopefully you kind
of get what it is now
so you find an opportunity you find a
deal negotiate the price pass it on to
an investor take your fee never own it
the great thing about it is there's no
risk or there's very very little risk
because when you buy a house what are
the risks well the risk is that you
can't rent it out the risk is that it
goes down in value the risk is that the
tenants trashed the property there are
risks whereas when you are packaging a
property and passing on to somebody else
the only risk you have is the risk of
having a bad reputation or a bad
conscience of passing on a bad property
but financially speaking
you have zero risks you have no risks
financially because you don't ever own
the house you'll just finding it and
passing it on to somebody else so that's
the first pro the second Pro is it can
be a very very Luke
TIF and I mean very lucrative I I've
sold hundreds of these deals on average
if you find a beer and you pass it on to
an investor they'll pay you between two
and five thousand pounds now you might
think why would someone pay you
thousands of pounds to go and find a
property and the reason is is because
the probably the most expensive thing
that you're ever gonna buy is a house
generally speaking if I say to someone
what's the most expensive thing you've
ever bought it's a house maybe followed
by a wedding maybe a car and then
generally you might buy small things
every day like food go out for dinners
now if you are paying someone to find
you a nice dinner where's a good place
to go and eat oh it's probably this
place you might pay some tip somebody a
couple of pound a few pounds because
you're only spending 50 pounds on the
dinner but when you're spending 50
thousand pounds on an investment or
maybe five hundred thousand pounds
something so big something so expensive
it's a property investment do you think
that you've been prepared to pay
somebody a couple thousand pounds to not
only find you a good deal but also to
negotiate the price down if someone's
negotiated a property from 100,000 to
80,000 they've knocked off 20,000 pounds
would you pay them two thousand pounds
to do that and the answer is of course
so as a deal sorcerer if you're out
looking for properties and you're
knocking down the prices and you're
negotiating good deals you are paid
handsomely to do that so there's no risk
the second thing it is very very
lucrative the third great thing about
deal sourcing is you are getting paid to
scalp the market for good property
investments and what's going to happen
if you're a deal sorcerer is you're
going to come across such good property
investments some of them are gonna be so
good and you're gonna get them so cheap
and they're gonna be such great
investments that it's going to pain you
to sell them for a measly two grand
you're gonna be like man I've found this
house it's it's 200 grand but I've got
it down to 150 and all
so when I buy it I'm gonna be able to
get some planning permission and push
the value up and I'm gonna rent it out
and such a good deal I want five grand
and you'll sell it for five grand and
then another one will come along just as
good even better and you're like I don't
even wanna let this go for five grand
and what you'll do is you'll think
actually know what I want this myself
and you'll find a way of financing it
yourself you'll probably use your
property investors that you've built up
as a deal sorcerer and you'll get them
to fund it but you're going to end up
being a property investor as a deal
sorcerer not just a property investor
but the kind of property investor that
gets the absolute creme of the creme
deals so that's the great things about
being a deal sorcerer they're not so
great things about being a deal sorcerer
are firstly it comes with a lot of
responsibility because if you're passing
deals on to investors and they're
trusting you and taking your word for it
and paying you thousands of pounds
because of a lot of responsibility so I
highly recommend a couple things firstly
get educated and get good make sure that
you're only finding good deals and
secondly make sure that you have proper
terms and conditions with your investors
so that they know that you've found the
property you've negotiated it but it
doesn't mean that you're responsible
forever and ever that this property is
going to be a good investment they have
to do their own research their own due
diligence and you're gonna have to make
that really clear in the terms and
conditions so that's the first con the
second con is you don't actually as a
deal sorcerer unless you systemize it
and start employing people which is
possible it doesn't give you passive
income so if you buy a property and you
rent it out it's going to keep giving
you rent every single month whereas
there's a deal sorcerer you have to keep
working keep working keep working to
getting paid some of my students tell me
Samuel it's not passive income but it is
massive income and I can use the profits
to invest into property that's going to
give me a passive income and there's a
really good argument in that but my
experience as a deal sorcerer and as a
property investor says that deal
sourcing does come with a lot of work it
does come with a lot of headaches you've
got investors calling you it's not
something that you can do you know one
hour a week this is gonna be something
you're going to really have to dedicate
your time to however if you could do one
deal a week
that's gonna give you about 10,000
pounds a month and I've got many many
students that are doing that and more so
it is lucrative part of the con is it's
gonna come with some hard work the last
con of Deal sourcing is there are a lot
of people that call themselves deal
sources that have never sold a deal and
they spam Facebook groups and they hound
estate agents and they do it all wrong
so with some people with some
professionals deal sources I've got a
little bit of a bad rep and people think
oh there's so many deal sources but let
me tell you this I know there's a lot of
people that call themself deal sources
but actually people doing it properly
that I've learned how to do it
step-by-step and good deal sources
there's not that many so if you learn
how to find good deals how do it network
with investors and you learn how to do
it properly you will be able to sell
deals very very quickly and make a lot
of money doing it so if you want to
learn more about deals selling or deal
packaging whatever you want to call it
as a strategy my advice would be I do
regularly run training webinars advanced
training webinars for free where I teach
you more about deal sourcing so if you
want to register so that you're the
first to know and I'm gonna be running
one of these live webinars then in the
description box below you can just put
your details in and I'll keep you posted
on any future training that I'm running
also if you want to learn more about
deal sourcing right now I have done
videos on YouTube before you can check
those out right there also don't forget
to subscribe to the channel you can
subscribe right there subscribe
turn the notification bell on smash a
like drop a comment thank you so much
for watching I'll see you next time